in August 2017 hurricane Harvey made
landfall in Southeast Texas dumping more
than a meter and a half of water on the
Houston area in four days
it was the wettest hurricane in US
history causing extensive flooding and a
hundred and twenty-five billion dollars
in damage so after the storm where did
all of that water go the Earth's crust
is surprisingly elastic it actually
sinks under the immense weight of new
water like what was released by Harvey
so it kind of behaves like a mattress in
a way so if I was to sit down on a
mattress
I would I would depress that mattress
with just because my weight right and so
I can measure my own weight based on how
much I depress that mattress to track
the water researchers use GPS satellites
to measure fluctuations and elevation of
the Earth's crust
subsidence down and up lift up and so
you could use that little measuring
stick of the kind of the the amount of
depression to figure out the weight of
the water the land around Houston sank
as much as 20 millimeters during
Hurricane Harvey with a clear pattern
left in the crust that moved across the
Gulf Coast for seven days consistent
with Harvey's position the GPS not only
allows us to figure out where that water
is and how much occurs but it allows us
to track how it dissipates how quickly
dissipates some how much dissipates and
the eight days following Harvey's
landfall 30% of the storm water was
stored on land as standing water sixty
percent of the storm water immediately
drained into the ocean in Galveston Bay
and the remaining 10 percent was lost to
evaporation it took five full weeks for
the water stored on land to dissipate
through evaporation or ground water
runoff okay we can do for Harvey that's
easy because there's so much water that
weight was so large that compression
that mattress is gonna be really easy to
see in the data so the next step is this
okay what about other smaller more
frequent hurricanes have less water
could we apply the same type of analysis
the ability to track daily changes in
the movement of water during extreme
events and help flood managers better
prepare for storms which will strike
with increased frequency and ferocity
as global warming causes the oceans
temperatures to rise if we have any hope
of weathering these future storms we
must remember that as my mom always says
all your do plan is planning to fail
[Music]